Taran Butler always makes me just a
little bit
the woman jizz I had no idea
[Music]
hi I'm Gerald Butler and I'm going to be
reading thirst tweets I want general
Butler to lick cherry flavored jello off
my finger why is life so unfair hey hey
don't give up life's not over yet
might still happen I want to buy a condo
then jenner Butler's chest here who is
currently sleeping with Jeff and Butler
they're lucky
it's nice chesty Oh Godspeed you ah so
you're the one I heard somebody saw that
their condos are for sale just get in
touch with my agent and I'm sure we can
do you a deal I've got your info by the
way I'll be in touch
I really don't have celebrity crushes
but I would like to be aired all from
Gerard Butler's face so okay Jared
Butler could punch me in the face and I
would still say thanks daddy is this my
kid I would claim Jenner Butler like a
tree and never let go
sounds like most of my ex-girlfriends
Jerry can spit on me anytime yeah I know
this person that's why at anytime again
it says yeah I will
no that's good so you know I might I
might I'm supposed to eat them watching
300 and wondering how I could possibly
have forgotten the majesty of Gerard
Butler's thighs yeah I've kind of
forgotten myself I think it's time to
get back into some 3-hundred workouts
because I miss the majesty of my thighs
and what can I just suffocate to our
Butler with my boobs already mm-hmm
definitely I basically only watch PS I
Love You for Jared Butler sexy bedroom
dance he took when I watch it every day
Hillary was okay but that dance
something like this and then that's what
I'm my tummy woman I know
Jared Butler's eye is a gift from God
I'm going to disagree with that I think
that's actually fairly accurate
reporting just put a Jerry Butler movie
on I'd lick that man's butthole from
balls to back yeah okay that future
thing I am touched and honored by these
incredibly deep and profound thoughts
you guys have been having about my beard
and [ __ ] and I just want to say that
I'm generally around for some of these
things they actually I'm an impact like
adventure I like new things so some of
these things actually sounded like fun
so you know how to find me
just look me down and let's talk
[Music]